[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend ihnen allen das sportliche
in der sendung übernimmt heute norbert
lehmann guten abend doch von mir unser
heutiger überblick mit den neuesten
entwicklungen zum krieg den konsequenzen
und zur pandemie
metropolen unter beschuss die ukraine
befürchtet eine bevorstehende einnahme
von großstädten russland gibt erstmals
offiziell militärische probleme zu
was tun gegen teures tanken einen benzin
rabatt will die fdp die union fordert
eine mehrwertsteuersenkung
und die zahlen steigen aber auflagen
entfallen angesichts zunehmender corona
infektionen warnen experten davor jetzt
zu viele maßnahmen zu beenden
seit fast drei wochen tobt krieg in
europa und zum ersten mal das offizielle
eingeständnis es läuft nicht nach plan
so der chef der russischen nationalgarde
zum symbol für den krieg gegen
zivilisten wurde zuletzt ein angriff auf
eine entbindungsklinik in mariupol die
stadt eben südosten steht immer noch
unter beschuss was das konkret für die
menschen heißt damit beginnt der bericht
von christoph des der l und markus
twickler
draußen schlagen beim 1 drin in einem
krankenhaus von mario pohl muss es
weitergehen kinder werden geboren auch
die zweier frauen die helfer aus einer
bombardierten anderen klinik hierher
brachten eine dritte frau lieferten sie
mit schweren verletzungen an der hüfte
ein stunden lang kämpfen die ärzte um
das leben von mutter und kind
wir machten einen kaiserschnitt aber das
baby war leblos wir versuchten alles
danach versuchten wir die mutter zu
retten auch vergeblich beide starben
wie es um das krankenhaus herum aussieht
drohen bilder des ukrainischen militärs
lassen es an mario pohl und der beschuss
einwohner in etwa 160 autos sollen das
heute heraus geschafft haben der
hilfskonvoi rhein ist wieder nicht
durchgekommen
um das leid zu beenden drängt der
ukrainische präsident auf ein direktes
gespräch mit seinem kriegsgegner putin
auch heute wieder von neuen
verhandlungen beider seiten
unsere delegation hat ein klares ziel
eintreffen bei der präsidentin
herbeizuführen das treffen von dem ich
sicher bin die menschen warten drauf
doch wieder werden die gespräche über
die zukunft der ukraine ergebnislos
unterbrochen
auch die frontlinien heute kaum
verändert während die lage immer
bedrohlicher wird luftschläge treffen
die hauptstadt auch ein wohnhaus neun
stockwerke hoch eine ältere frau kann
noch gerettet werden einen mann finden
die feuerwehrleute tot in seiner wohnung
aus der stadt heraus meldet sich der
aufgebrachte bruder des bürgermeisters
ein bus von einer rakete getroffen
ausgelöschte leben diese bilder zeigen
die wahrheit von russlands krieg gegen
die ukraine putins krieg so sieht er aus
aber er sieht auch so aus wie heute in
donetsk einer der separatisten städte im
osten mehrere agenturen verbreiten diese
bilder dazu melden die prorussischen
kämpfer mindestens 20 menschen ums leben
gekommen durch die trümmer einer
abgefangenen ukrainischen rakete ukraine
dementiert man sei über donetsk heute
keine angriffe geflogen aussage steht
gegen aussage
schauen wir jetzt nach odessa das ist
die drittgrößte metropole der ukraine
die millionenstadt liegt im süden direkt
am schwarzen meer und die hafenstadt ist
militärisch und ökonomisch von hoher
strategischer bedeutung weil dort unter
anderem das hauptquartier der
ukrainischen marine liegt noch ist oder
es hat zwar kein direktes kampfgebiet
aber die stadt wappnet sich schon für
einen möglichen angriff aus odessa
katrin eigendorf
panzersperren von bürgern aus
eisenbahnschienen zusammengeschweißt
mitten in odessa der drittgrößten stadt
der ukraine nur mit sondergenehmigung
kommt man durch die barrikaden soldaten
dürfen wir nicht zeigen aber mit den
menschen können wir sprechen ich treffe
viele die sich auf ein leben im
ausnahmezustand eingerichtet haben
ich habe angst aber ich gehe nirgendwo
hin ich bin alleine ich weiß gar nicht
wohin ich gehen sollte ich habe mein
ganzes leben hier verbracht ich bleibe
hier sicher nie besessen
wie in vielen städten der ukraine haben
sich die bürger auch in odessa
organisiert packen kisten für die
soldaten an der front viele von ihnen
junge menschen die entschlossen sind ihr
land zu verteidigen zu bleiben
wir müssen absolut alles tun um zu
gewinnen und danach werden wir unser
land wieder aufbauen denn wir lieben es
sehr ich möchte kein flüchtling werden
dafür werde ich beten und ich werde hier
bis zum ende bleiben
die meisten geschäfte sind längst
geschlossen viele menschen vor allem
familien mit kindern haben die stadt
verlassen im café ocean drängeln sich
die zurückgebliebenen noch gibt es
cappuccino und latte macchiato doch das
gefühl von normalität ist lange
verschwunden
wer wollte der ist längst weg alle
anderen sind geblieben was haben wir für
eine wahl weg laufen dann werden wir
unser ganzes leben lang weglaufen
und so bereiten sie sich auch in odessa
darauf vor dass ihre stadt die nächste
sein könnte die von russischen panzern
umzingelt wird
und gehen wir jetzt direkt nach wo der
satz so katrin eigendorf frankreich und
deutschland seien zuletzt ja wenig
chancen für diplomatischen fortschritt
russland und die ukraine klingt ein
bisschen optimistischer wie fühlt sich
das an in odessa
die bevölkerung hier in und deshalb
setzt überhaupt nicht auf
friedensgespräche ich habe hier heute
niemanden getroffen der irgendeine
hoffnung daran knüpft dass es zu einer
baldigen einigung zwischen russland und
der ukraine kommen kann und das spiegelt
sich eigentlich auch in den ukrainischen
medien so wieder friedensverhandlungen
fortschritte der beiden delegationen das
ist hier kein großes thema was
diskutiert wird in der ukraine wird
zurzeit diskutiert wie kann man sich am
besten gegen die angriffe der russen die
ja immer weiter zunehmen zur wehr setzen
wie löst man die humanitäre katastrophe
und wie kann man weiter druck auf die
nato und europa ausüben der ukraine in
diesem krieg beizustehen die
verhandlungen werden am 15 märz
weitergehen aber wie gesagt die
erwartungen sind sehr gering dankeschön
nach odessa katrin eigendorf war das ja
natürlich fliehen immer mehr menschen
aus der ukraine
das bundesinnenministerium hat sich bei
den vielen bürgern bedankt die den
geflüchteten helfen oder sie zu hause
bei sich aufnehmen auch heute kamen
wieder viele in deutschland an wie hier
im sächsischen görlitz die behörden
haben jetzt insgesamt rund
147.000 geflohen de registriert die
tatsächliche zahl dürfte höher liegen
ukrainische kriegsflüchtlinge brauchen
nämlich kein visum und müssen sich bei
der einreise auch nicht melden wenn sie
den geflüchteten und den menschen in der
ukraine mit geldspenden helfen möchten
dann können sie das beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
hier ist die bahn de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine
und alle infos finden sie auch unter
spenden zdf.de oder auf der zdf
textseite 890
welchen beitrag kann das nato-land
türkei in russland ukraine krieg noch
leisten zu beiden ländern pflegt ankara
gute beziehungen das und mehr war thema
heute beim antrittsbesuch von
bundeskanzler scholz beim türkischen
präsidenten erdogan über den uns jetzt
glück weil protein formiert ein
antrittsbesuch in einer schwierigen
politischen und militärischen
krisensituation in den vergangenen
jahren waren die bilateralen beziehungen
zwischen ankara und berlin nicht selten
von spannungen und schweren differenzen
gekennzeichnet diesmal standen die
gespräche unter dem eindruck des
russischen angriffskriegs auf die
ukraine der bundeskanzler unterstrich
dass beide nato partner die russische
aggression in aller deutlichkeit
verurteilten dass die türkei wegen ihrer
engen wirtschaftlichen beziehungen zu
russland die sanktionen nicht mitträgt
wollte schulz nicht kommentieren er
lobte aber die türkische hilfe für die
ukraine inklusive waffenlieferungen wir
sind uns völlig einig dass es so schnell
wie möglich einen waffenstillstand geben
muss denn das ist jetzt richtig damit
nicht weiteres menschenleben gefährdet
wird es muss sicherer korridore geben
für zivilisten dass sie sich aus den
gefährdeten orten unbeschadet
herausgegeben können präsident erdogan
hob die türkischen bemühungen um eine
lösung des konflikts hervor mit dem
russisch ukrainischen außenminister
treffen in antalya sei ein anfang
gemacht den gelte es jetzt zu vertiefen
in einer lage würde er krieg mit
unverminderter härte weiter geht ist ein
solches diplomatisches treffen schon ein
erfolg wir setzen alles daran um auf
diesem weg eine waffe zu erreichen
von einem guten bilateralen verhältnis
sprach scholz und nannte das
funktionierende flüchtlings abkommen
auch wenn es weiter differenzen gebe
natürlich gibt es das gehört zu den
dingen dazu die gesagt werden müssen
auch
differenzen belastungen unterschiedliche
ansichten die wir haben etwa wenn es um
fragen von menschenrechten und
rechtsstaatlichkeit geht oder für die
nahe zukunft wurden gemeinsame
arbeitsgruppen auf hohe beamtenebene
vereinbart die die zusammenarbeit weiter
ausbauen soll
sie wissen seit kriegsbeginn steigen die
energiepreise und jetzt hat die
bundesregierung weitere entlastungen
angekündigt besonders steil nach oben
ging es ja bei den kraftstoffen zuletzt
kostete der liter super e10 im schnitt 2
eur 19 für diesel waren es sogar zwei
euro 30 aber wie gegensteuern die union
fordert steuersenkungen die fdp will
einen tank rabatt mehr von karl
hinterleitner
die 250 geratenen sichtweite viele
autofahrer sind am limit oder darüber
hinaus der staat müsste die folgen
dieser preis explosion jetzt abfedern
meint der bundesfinanzminister es geht
darum die bürgerinnen und bürger die auf
das auto angewiesen sind aber auch die
gewerbetreibenden
für die die gestiegenen kraftstoffpreise
eine
wirtschaftliche belastung da stehen sehr
schnell zu unterstützen beim sogenannten
tank rabatt soll dem kunden eine
bestimmte summe erlassen werden die der
bund die betreiber anschließend
erstattet mindestens 20 cent pro liter
der koalitionspartner nicht überzeugt
der plan sei allenfalls eine teillösung
entscheidend ist dass wir ein
gesamtpaket haben was in der koalition
abgestimmt ist das auch anreize schafft
marktwirtschaftlich für sparen und für
effizienz und das nicht nur benzin im
blick hat sondern auch heizkosten und
strom gegen den plan spricht sich die
opposition aus zwar müsse man bei den
spritpreisen dringend handeln einen tank
rabatt aber zu umständlich sie ihn nicht
wie einen rabattgutschein
unbürokratisch sein soll die
tankstellenpächter müssten das auch
vorfinanzieren insofern bleiben wir bei
unserem vorschlag steuern senken
mineralölsteuer mehrwertsteuer auf den
spritpreis dass es sofort wirksam
entlastet braucht keine bürokratie
einigkeit herrscht darüber dass es
entlastungen geben muss wie die genau
aussehen das will die bundesregierung im
laufe der woche entscheiden
die zuletzt beschworenen zeitenwende in
deutschland ist vor allem ja auch
militär politisch gemeint 100 milliarden
euro sollen mittelfristig in die
modernisierung der bundeswehr investiert
der veritas langfristig aufgestockt
werden und die neuausrichtung der
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
nimmt langsam konkrete konturen an zum
beispiel was den ersatz für den in die
jahre gekommenen kampf der tornado
angeht mehr von andreas ruppert
die f35 in ihrem element das zur zeit
wohl modernste kampfflugzeug der welt
wird künftig auch in den deutschen
luftwaffe dienst die 35 bietet ein
einzigartiges
kooperationsmodell zial mit unseren nato
verbündeten und weiteren partnern in
europa auf putins aggressionen kann es
aus meiner sicht nur eine antwort geben
und das ist geschlossenheit in der nato
und glaubwürdige abschreckung putins
angriffskrieg hat dafür gesorgt dass es
nach dem jahrelangen hin und her über
die modernisierung der deutschen
kampfjet flotte plötzlich ganz schnell
geht der f-35 tarnkappen jet aus
amerikanischer produktion zum stückpreis
von um die 85 millionen dollar soll die
fast 40 jahre alten bundeswehr-tornados
ablösen
das ist jetzt erst mal der anfang weil
das eben wichtige sache ist ja seit
jahrzehnten diskutiert wird der tornado
fliegt nur bis ende der 20er jahre und
es ist gut dass das thema jetzt endlich
vom tisch geräumt wurde doch bis das
soweit ist dauert es noch denn nur mit
dem kauf der flugzeuge ist es nicht
getan auch neu ausgebildete piloten und
mechaniker braucht
ich kann mir auch vorstellen dass die
amerikaner das training der piloten der
techniker das gehört ja auch dazu schon
maschinen zur verfügung stellen wir uns
da nicht gehören aber ich gehe schon
davon aus dass das sicherlich noch
einige jahre dauern die alten system
betrieben werden müssen insbesondere
der erste schritt ist gemacht bis die 35
neuen kampfjets da sind wird weiterhin
der in die jahre gekommene tornado
deutschlands sicherheit verteilt
zum krieg in der ukraine gibt es gleich
nach wir uns wieder ein zdf spezial und
in unserer heute app haben wir mehr
informationen darüber wie und wo
bundeswehr und nato gerade ihre
streitkräfte verstärken jetzt kommen wir
zu corona erst der blick auf die zahlen
seit anfang märz geht der trend wieder
nach oben inzwischen liegt die sieben
tage incidents bei
1543 der märker institute wurden 92
1378 neuinfektionen innerhalb eines
tages gemeldet 13 1950 fälle mehr als am
montag vergangener woche
ja die zahlen steigen die maßnahmen aber
sollen zurückgefahren werden das ist die
aktuelle ausgangslage tatsächlich soll
ja entschieden werden wie es nach dem 19
märz weitergeht das bisherige
infektionsschutzgesetz läuft ja aus und
wie so oft bei corona es gibt
verschiedene meinungen und darüber eben
auch streit zb über die masken pflicht
in innenräumen last bohnsack die
momentane corona lage lässt so manchen
daran zweifeln dass die von der
regierung geplanten massiven lockerungen
tatsächlich angebracht sind virologen
waren vor dem wegfall von
schutzmaßnahmen wie der masken pflicht
ich glaube die restriktionen kann man
auslaufen lassen aber diese relativ
einfache und wirksame maßnahme der
masken pflicht um die zu schützen die
sich anders nicht schützen können die
gefährdet sind in bereichen wo sie
einfach hinein müssen die halte ich
notwendig für aufrecht zu erhalten es
grummelt hörbar in der ampel koalition
spd und grüne fordern die fdp zu
nachverhandlungen auf die masken pflicht
solle nicht nur im öffentlichen
nahverkehr sondern auch zum beispiel im
einzelhandel und der gastronomie weiter
gelten wir sind davon überzeugt dass
gewisse basis schutzmaßnahmen uns recht
gut durch diese pandemie gebracht haben
und in ihrer kosten nutzen abwägung
deutlich auf der positiven seite zu
bewerten sind ist ein instrument das
sehr viel wirkt und dafür relativ
geringen eingreift in den alltag der
menschen doch alle appelle scheinen zu
verhallen die fdp beharrt auf dem
vereinbarten auch bei der mast pflicht
ich baue darauf dass nach zwei jahren
pandemie die menschen eben auch
eigenverantwortung gelernt haben und
auch wissen was es heißt warum soll ich
in einem einzelhandelsgeschäft wo ich
der einzige kunde bin eine maske
aufsetzen wenn allerdings dort viele
kunden sind und es ist kein abstand zu
halten setze ich sie eigenverantwortlich
auf und ich glaube wir unterschätzen die
bevölkerung dar viele wissen damit
umzugehen keine erweiterte masken
pflicht mehr richtig zufrieden sein
dürfte damit nur die kleinste partei der
ampel koalition
besonders für alte und kranke menschen
kann eine corona infektion gefährlich
sein darum gilt für all diejenigen die
beruflich mit ihnen zu tun haben ab
mittwoch die berufsbezogene impfpflicht
davon betroffen sind zum beispiel
pflegerinnen und pfleger und natürlich
ist es in den einrichtungen aktuell ein
riesenthema nicola albrecht berichtet
aus brandenburg eine entspannte
kartenrunde am morgen ist im pflegeheim
salon berg in brandenburg endlich wieder
möglich auch wenn der korona schock bei
vielen hier noch tief sitzt 21 bewohner
waren hier noch bevor es die impfung gab
mit oder an corinna gestorben nun sind
fast alle geimpft nur eine mitarbeiterin
hat aktuell den schutz nicht ihr und
allen anderen ungeimpften im
gesundheitswesen droht nun im härtesten
fall arbeitsverbot schwierig für die vom
fachkräftemangel gebeutelte branche denn
hier zählt jeder einzelne wir können uns
einfach schlichtweg nicht leisten in der
pflege auf personal zu verzichten ab
mittwoch gilt die arbeitgeber im
gesundheitswesen müssen alle ungeimpften
mitarbeiter den behörden melden wer das
nicht tut oder sie beschäftigt muss mit
strafen rechnen
das ist eine ganz klare
ordnungswidrigkeit es gibt einen
bußgeldkatalog der für jeden einzelfall
strafen bis zu 2500 euro vorsieht
ungeimpfte arbeitnehmer müssen ebenfalls
mit bußgeldern rechnen arbeitsverbot
wäre die ultima ratio das rkw schätzt
auf grundlage freiwilliger angaben die
bundesweite impfquote im
gesundheitswesen auf rund 90 prozent
vielen betroffenen gibt dass sicherheit
jeden fall ist man geschützter wende
allerdings
schrumpft sind
bewohner und deren besucher müssen
übrigens nicht geimpft sein und so
plädieren viele pflegeverbände auch für
eine allgemeine impfpflicht statt der
einrichtungs bezogenen
jetzt zum wirecard skandal da hat die
staatsanwaltschaft münchen anklage gegen
den früheren unternehmenschef markus
braun erhoben und auch gegen zwei
weitere top-manager des insolventen
zahlungsdienstleisters ihnen wird unter
anderem gewerbsmäßiger bandenbetrug
vorgeworfen die wirecard chefetage soll
über jahre scheingeschäfte in
milliardenhöhe verbucht haben um das
damalige dax unternehmen über wasser zu
halten
wieder ist eine stimme verstummt die
noch selbst vom grauen der ns zeit
berichten konnte und wollte leon schwarz
baum ist im alter von 101 gestorben
schwarz baum überlebte die
konzentrationslager
auschwitz buchenwald und sachsenhausen
bis zuletzt war es ihm wichtig seine
geschichte zu erzählen aber auch sich
für gerechtigkeit einzusetzen
im laufenden prozess gegen einen
früheren ss wachmann sollte er als zeuge
aussagen
jetzt ein harter schnitt zum fußball
wetter soll ein altbekanntes gesicht
jetzt hertha bsc retten felix magath und
das ist schon eine überraschung denn
dessen letzte erfolge die liegen dann
doch schon einige zeit zurück magath
steht für disziplin fitness und hartes
training qualität kommt von quälen hat
er mal gesagt der 68 jährige felix
magath ist laut manager fredi bobic
genau das was hertha bsc jetzt braucht
eine starke persönlichkeit wie man das
sich einsetzt für
disziplin
eine klare und harte hand zeigen meter
niederlage am wochenende gegen gladbach
war der rettungsversuch von tayfun
korkut endgültig gescheitert trotz
investiert hat 375 millionen ist härter
tabellen 17 nach fünf jahren ohne
trainerjob musste er für seine härte
bekannte magath nun ein feines gespür im
abstiegskampf beweisen
gestern für sonntagsspiele in der
fußball-bundesliga wir schauen jetzt auf
die partien der beiden spitzenklubs
dortmund und leverkusen der bvb holt
drei punkte gegen bielefeld bayer
dagegen verliert das rheinische duell
und einen wichtigen spieler dazu zwei
leistungsträger am scheideweg der eine
kommt zurück nach siebenwöchiger
verletzungspause den anderen muss man
vom feld tragen nach kreuzbandriss im
knie die ideen von florian würz werden
leverkusen nun auf monate hinaus fehlen
im rheinischen duell profitierte erst fc
köln auch vom leverkusener
verletzungspech ein glücklicher 1
0-auswärtssieg des schwindlers treffer
die fans dürfen sich über platz sieben
freuen hollands eingewöhnung noch ohne
torerfolg aber er wird wichtig werden
für den bvb um die bayern noch an der
tabellenspitze anzugreifen
vorerst reicht ist das ein
stellvertreter das entscheidende tor
gegen bielefeld erzielt marius wolf
zumindest der frisur nach die norweger
nicht unähnlich und
alle tore alle höhepunkte dieses 26
spieltags bei uns zu sehen beim zdf
heute.de und in der heute
football superstar tom brady nacht
weiter und will nun doch seine
unvergleichliche karriere fortsetzen 40
tage nach seiner rücktrittsankündigung
machte er einen rückzieher der
quarterback will ein weiteres jahr für
die tampa bay buccaneers spiel und das
wird weltweit millionen fans freuen
vielen dank herr norbert wir haben zum
schluss noch ein zeichen für
menschlichkeit in kriegszeiten zwei
kinder sind aus der ukraine nach italien
geflohen victoria und dimitri neues land
neue schule aufregung was wird sie
erwarten und dann das
die ganze schule in habe sagt bmw nudow
willkommen hier sind die neuen nicht
allein eine tolle eine herzerwärmende
geste
so zum wetter folgendes neuer regen ist
unterwegs die natur braucht das sehr
dringend details gleich von präsident
ali ich empfehle ab 21 uhr 45 das heute
journal mit christian sievers und gleich
nach und das zdf spezial so viel vom
gesamten 19 uhr heute team schönen abend
schön dank und bis morgen
[Musik]
schon guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der regen des
heutigen tages hin mit diesem team
zusammen das verabschiedet sich
allmählich aber der nächste regen
kündigt sich schon an und zwar mit
diesem tief 4 das kommt in den
frühstunden im südwesten an und wird
entlang des mains und südlich davon
teilweise bis zu 20 liter auf den
quadratmeter bringen und das innerhalb
von zwölf stunden
wir schauen denn die nachts da gibt es
im osten nach nordosten hin noch
kompakte wolken mit regen und im norden
sonst aber ist es trocken und im süd
westen in den frühstunden neuer ring mit
diesem herannahenden tief und das bei
tiefsten temperaturen von minus zwei
grad im osten und fünf grad plus zum
beispiel am niederrhein morgen am
vormittag dann im südwesten regen und
sonst aber trockenes wetter teilweise
mit sonnenschein zum nachmittag schiebt
sich das tief weiter in die mitte und
dann regnet es vor allem hier entlang
des mains und auch nach osten hin bei
höchsten temperaturen von 14 grad zum
beispiel im osten deutschland c/o das
tief ankommt sieben bis neun grad nur
maximal 16 im südwesten sonnenschein
gibt es auch in den nächsten tagen und
es wird wärmer zum beispiel mittwoch bis
19 grad donnerstag gibt es ganz im
norden etwas regen ein schöner abend